Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis dans le jardin du Grand Point Virgule !
-Le jardin d'Eden.
Je suis avec Lucille
-Exactement, Lulu.
Vous l'avez vu dans ma toute première vidéo
dans laquelle elle disait qu'elle trouvait mon projet génial.
Dans la médiocrité, génial.
-Voilà.
C'est ça.
Et plus de 100 vidéos après, Lulu est là pour se faire mentaliser.
Est-ce-que tu aimes les super héros ?
-Oui.
Ouais ? les Marvel ?
-Vite fait.
Parce que mercredi prochain, Captain America sort au cinéma.
Et en fait, j'ai envie que tu deviennes Captain América pour moi.
-Ok. Très bien.
J'aime bien parce que Lulu est prête à tout.
Vas-y il n'y a pas de problème. Regarde j'avais mon costume !
Alors Captain América se déplace de ville en ville, pour défendre les Etats-Unis.
C'est ça son truc. C'est son objectif.
C'est comme si nous avons Captain France avec nous.
Mais...dans ce cas ça marche moins bien.
Captain America se déplace donc de ville en ville pour sauver les Etats-Unis de tous les dangers.
D'accord ?
Tu vas donc nous emmener dans une de ces villes et je vais essayer de trouver laquelle.
Ca va ? Jusque-là c'est clair ?
-Tout est clair.
Après c'est à toi de savoir si c'est de la déduction ou de l'influence.
Moi, je vais noter une ville sur mon carnet, d'accord ?
-Ok.
C'est parti.
Je vais le faire devant la caméra comme ça tout le monde va voir ce que je fais.
Du coup tu peux te mettre en face cam si tu veux.
Viens avec moi Lulu.
Recule un peu.
Donc Lulu tu ne peux pas voir ce que j'écris mais les internautes voient.
Voilà ma prédiction.
Et je le referme, c'est sur la première feuille, il n'y a pas d'embrouille.
Ok ?
-Ok.
Imagine-toi dans la peau de Captain America et on t'appelle pour une mission:
"Hallo Captain America, il y a un problème."
D'ailleurs tu décides de partir avec quel moyen de transport ?
Avec un bus ? Un train ? Un avion ? Tu prends ton bouclier ? Comment ça se passe ?
-Je m'envole directement.
Tu t'envoles ?
-Oui, je m'envole
Mais il vole ou pas Captain America ?
-Oui, il a une cape...
En effet il a peut être une cape, mais je ne sais pas si il vole...
D'accord, alors tu décides de voler, parce que tu es la Captain America qui fait ce qu'elle veut.
Donc tu es Captain America et tu décides de t'envoler.
Tu t'envoles, tu surplombes la côte Ouest, la côte Est,
tu vois toutes les villes autour de toi...
Cite moi les 3 premières villes qui te viennent à l'esprit, celles que tu vois.
-Boston, New-York, Seatle.
Ok, et là on t'appelle, tu reçois un coup de fil.
-Hallo ?
-"Captain America ?"
-Oui, en effet c'est bien moi.
-"Nous avons un très gros problème."
C'est une mise en scène incroyable !
[rires]
-En effet, quel gros problème !
-"Nous avons un problème dans une ville, mais je ne sais pas trop laquelle,
je pense Captain que vous êtes le seul héros à connaitre le nom de la ville dans laquelle il y a un problème.
Je raccroche, car ce message de veut rien dire Captain America."
Alors, apparemment il y un problème dans une ville, il y a que toi qui connait le nom de cette ville dans laquelle il y a un problème.
Est-ce-que tu peux dire à la caméra dans quelle ville il y a un problème selon toi ?
-Selon moi... enfin je suis sûre puisque c'est moi Captain America,
selon moi, il y aurait un problème à Miami.
A Miami ?
D'accord, alors pour toi, il y aurait un problème à Miami.
-Oui.
Et moi depuis le départ dans mon carnet j'avais écrit une petite prédiction concernant le nom de cette ville,
en effet il y a un problème à...
Miami !!!
Merci Captain America !
-Je t'en prie !
Ca va ? Tu as aimé ce tour ?
-Oui, c'était cool !
-Moi au départ, je me suis dit "non, il ne va pas me mentaliser, il m'aurait prévenu quand même..."
et quand tu as dis; "Je vais deviner...", je me suis dit "Oh mince !"
C'est vrai que j'oublie toujours de prévenir le tour qu'on va faire.
-J'espérais que tu réussisses ton tour, mais ça me faisait flippé malgré tout.
Regardez ! Cette meuf est vraiment Captain America !
J'ai eu peur que tu te le reprennes en revers !
[rires]
-C'était super !
Est-ce-que ça t'as impressionné ?
-Oui !
Est-ce-que tu as été complice ?
-J'étais très complice.
[rires]
Elle doit être encore mentalisée... c'est pas possible...
-Non, dans le sens malicieuse du terme.
Merci beaucoup Lucille, c'est une metteuse en scène de folie, une auteure de folie,
Dans le descriptif je vous mets le lien du site Internet de la compagnie de Lucille.
Comme ça vous pouvez la suivre, voir son travail,  ce qu'elle fait, où elle est...
Si cette vidéo vous a plu n'oubliez pas, vous pouvez nous le faire savoir à Lucille et à moi.
En laissant un petit... pouce en l'air !
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaine, et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour un prochain MentalVlog.
Ciao !